now ethnic serbs living in Northern
Kosovo who've been blocking roads for
nearly three weeks have agreed to
dismantle their barricades Syrian
president Alexander buckchurch said he
brokered the move the crisis erupted
after the Detention of a former ethnic
serve policeman for terrorism
ethnic tensions have simmered since
Kosovo declared independence from Serbia
in 2008 many serbs in the north still
regard the area as part of Serbia
well it's bringing loose gunavigamark
here he's head of the European Union
rule of law mission in Kosovo now that
uh was set up to support local
institutions after Kosovo declared its
independence from Serbia in 2008.
welcome to the program first of all
Serbia's President says the barricades
and Northern Kosovo will be removed what
would you say that's a significant step
towards de-escalation
well first of all we haven't seen the
barricades being removed yet
um only a handful of small local roads
have been cleared so far but all the
major barricades still remain and it's
our understanding that yes this is part
of this understanding or or agreement
that they should be removed so we are
waiting quite anxiously for that to
happen together with our colleagues here
from from NATO K4
well the uh the tensions surrounding
course about have been simmering for
years you know that as well as anyone
are you convinced that the players
involved in this are committed to
peaceful coexistence
well I certainly hope that everyone
would like to have peace here in the
region in general
um we we all know what's going on in
Ukraine and the last thing that Europe
needs now right now is another armed
conflict what we've seen here in Kosovo
Northern Kosovo and in terms of
relations between
Belgrade and Christina over the past
year is uh kind of on and off crisis
over what seems to be minor issues such
as which kind of license plates should
be be allowed in Northern Kosovo in in
particular whether you've still been
using old Serbian issued license plates
but of course it's it's this is just the
tip of the iceberg
their whole set of agreements reached
under the the dialogue
um already almost 10 years ago that were
implemented in particular uh the
integration of Kosovo serbs in Northern
Kosovo into the Kosovo police force uh
the Judiciary was also integrated and a
number of other institutions
unfortunately over a month ago uh Kosovo
serve police officers withdrew and also
from the Judiciary which created a
security and rule of law vacuum in
Northern kosur and the four northernmost
municipalities Kosovo and that vacuum
still persists if you don't have law
enforcement if you don't have police we
have tried to fill it as the Euro local
Mission we have a small police force
here with the limited mandate we're
working closely with the Kosovo police
we only act at their explicit request we
also have kefir of course but they're
military so for them it's they they
don't do law enforcement so this vacuum
still
um persists and that's why we urge
everyone to to return to to the
negotiating table and if there's still
issues with the dialogue agreements that
have already been reached they need to
be resolved and they need to move on I
think now and and look at the the
broader aspects of a comprehensive
agreement that will lead to to Mutual
recognition also of of both both
countries well there you go you've
touched on the core issue in this uh in
the tensions in that region Serbia still
refuses to recognize kosovo's
Independence so what prospects do you
see for resolving that
well I think it's important to to keep
working uh first of all we have a
mandate to work here in in Kosovo first
of all uh Kosovo has made a lot of
progress I would say in in terms of rule
of law in terms of economic developments
there's still a lot of work to do in
terms of strengthening the independence
of Judiciary we're monitoring the
Judiciary and as part of this
understanding that we hope uh now is has
been been reached also we will monitor
um cases involving uh so-called
non-majority
members of the Kosovo police population
we've been doing this already for quite
some time we've monitored for instance
the case of Oliver Ivanovic uh one of
the few prominent Kosovo Serb
um uh opposition politicians who was
murdered in mitravitza four years ago
right we're also monitoring a lot of
high profile corruption cases in in
Kosovo in in general
um I think we we are Partners here
because
will needs our our support I'd like to
think rule of law is an issue for the
whole whole region not just in in
Western Balkans these days also in the
European Union we see a lot of
discussion